hey hey what is happening youtube in
this video i'm going to be giving
a hundred people bear in mind my average
video might get two or three thousand
views i'm gonna be giving a hundred
people access to my personal phone
number and i'm gonna add you to a
private whatsapp group okay i'll tell
you exactly how that works in a minute
but first i wanted to tell you there's
three things if you want to win if you
want to win in property if you want to
win in business there's three things
that you've got to do if you do these
three things it's going to put you head
and shoulders above everybody else so
keep watching until the end of the video
i'll tell you exactly how the what's up
group works how you can be added to it
but i'm going to only be capping this
because i think what's up cap there
their numbers had on my phone to be
pinging every 30 seconds
so first thing if you want to win in
property you want to win in business you
need to have a goal
now i think the biggest reason that
people fail is not because they
don't know they've got to have a goal
but it's they don't know how to actually
create a goal so it's like yeah i know i
need a goal but what is my goal so i
thought in this youtube video i thought
i'd just go ahead and give you
a goal
so your goal bear morning september your
goal
is to be making 2 000 pounds a month
wrote this down
okay i want you to be making 2 000
pounds a month
in passive income
per month
buy because if it's not got a date it's
just a dream
by
january the 31st of
2022. that's the goal
to making 2 000 pounds a month in
passive income
by end of january right now we're in
september so we've got september october
november three and a half months to
become
um financially free
because if you're making two thousand
pounds a month in passive income
that means that you've replaced the
average salary which means that
technically you should be financially
free so that's the goal second thing
is you need to be able to
um understand the numbers yes this is a
people a people game but it's also a
numbers game and i see a lot of people
in this property business and they're
really out there they've got lots of
energy they take lots of action but they
just don't know how to work the basic
numbers of property real estate business
they don't know um you know what the
difference is between revenue
profit margins and gross net uh direct
costs overheads they don't know the
difference between the costs so
in property the biggest thing you need
to be able to work out is the return on
investment you need to be able to work
out cash on cash roi
how do you know what you're going to put
in to a deal how do you work out what
you're going to get out of that deal and
then you divide the two together so
i've put together a spreadsheet
a return on investment spreadsheet like
an excel spreadsheet which
will really help you work out the return
on investment on deals um in fact as
part of the whatsapp group which 100
people are going to get access to um in
that whatsapp group i'm going to include
the full return on investment
spreadsheet okay so you're going to get
that and there's going to be
details of how to get that in the
description below
the third thing
once you've got a goal and you
understand your numbers
the third thing is you just got to take
massive massive action take massive
action it really surprises me you know
when i see people um
opportunities
on the table and they just haven't got
the courage
or or they haven't got the time to
actually go and take action
um i mean for example i had someone just
message my instagram and say samuel i'm
really really desperate to become
financially free um you know do you run
any training programs i was like yeah
man i've got a property investors crash
cart he's like oh my gosh that's amazing
when is it where is it uh and i gave him
a a list of all the dates the six dates
across the country and he was oh i live
in london but the london one sold out
when's the next one i'm like
dude man
you just gotta travel down to heath rowe
or something or wolverhampton
it's not far
but but that's the thing people take
themselves out the game with the with
the very first hurdle you've got to have
massive massive action in fact if you
want to come to the property investors
crash course
i'll also leave a link in the
description as well to the crash course
so you can do that um but take massive
massive action when you see an
opportunity an opportunity to go for
dinner with a potential mentor um an
opportunity to go and meet an estate
agent with a potential deal an
opportunity um to attend a training
program an opportunity to
sell an investor on a joint venture
proposal
you've got to take the opportunity
you've got to pick up the phone you've
got to attend the meeting so if you do
those three things i've got the goal for
you already done
the numbers i'm going to give you access
to the to the return on investors return
investment spreadsheet and then number
three is take massive action um if you
want to be one of the first hundred to
take massive action and to get into my
whatsapp group how does that work so
what how that works is i'm taking 100
names and numbers
adding them to a private whatsapp group
and i'm going to be notifying you of
special things that are going on like
for instance the eviction people go i
didn't hear about the eviction or they
might hear about courses and it's too
late or offers opportunities on social
media when it's too late so um i'm going
to be just notifying people of what's
going on um i'm going to be giving you
access to the return investment
spreadsheet and and how much is it to be
part of this whatsapp group it's
completely free all right so i'll leave
a link in the description to get
access to get onto the whatsapp group
i'll send you a message let's stay in
touch because it's really important that
you're around the right people and i
hope to see you hit your goal of
financial freedom by january
2022 baby i'm rooting for you